l'usage du français étant déclin à
Montréal au profit de l'anglais les deux
langues font partie de la réalité
quotidienne de bien des travailleurs si
je m'adresse à quelqu'un qui parle juste
en anglais pour préfère parler en
anglais donc ça date beaucoup le
français quand même entre nous et sinon
oui l'anglais ça dépend mon travail
beaucoup avec des gens à l'étranger
aussi donc pour renverser la tendance
François Legault veut que 100% des
personnes immigrantes choisies par
Québec soit francophone on va orienter
nos mesures de recrutement en fonction
de la connaissance du fait français en
fonction du fait que les pays seront
franco-tropes donc ils sont par exemple
locuteur d'une langue d'origine latine
l'an dernier la province a accueillie
plus de 50 000 immigrants plus de la
moitié sont des immigrants dit
économiques qui ont été sélectionnés par
Québec c'est cette portion qui devra
être complètement francophone à l'heure
actuelle près de 80% d'entre eux ont une
connaissance du français
ça avec les besoins le ministre de
l'Économie Satan à ce qu'il y ait des
exceptions pour certaines entreprises
qui ont besoin de travailleurs étrangers
hautement qualifiés il y a plus de 300
millions de locuteurs francophones de
Parlement donc je peux pas croire que
parmi ce bassin là ce qui voudront
immigrer qu'il y en aura pas
suffisamment qui correspondront au
profil dont on a besoin sur le plan
économique donc pour moi c'est pas
mission impossible
économique francophone mais on pense que
le seuil actuel est vraiment raisonnable
la présidente de l'Association
québécoise des avocats en droit de
l'immigration crée notamment que des
candidats qualifiés soient exclus on ne
doit pas se limiter à des personnes qui
ont une langue francophone parce que des
candidats vraiment intéressants qui vont
contribuer à la société québécoise tout
en apprenant le continuant
l'apprentissage du français ici les
verbes la francisation d'ailleurs est un
autre élément important mais les
nouveaux arrivants ne peuvent porter à
eux seul le fardeau de la survie du
Français estiment cet ancien professeur
des étudiants qui sortaient de chez nous
après 30 semaines de cours à temps plein
donc 900 heures de cours qui parlaient
qui est communiqué en français on l'a
rencontré quelques mois plus tard et ils
avaient ils avaient perdu une partie de
leur compétences parce que au travail
comme quoi l'avenir de la langue se joue
surtout à l'intérieur de nos frontières
ici Sébastien Desrosiers Radio-Canada
Montréal